welcome to this video playing olympus
who is that axel Bachman yeah I keep
overlooking this little thingy there you
know this flag always think there's a
dutch flag but it isn't that's Paraguay
Paraguay so this King's fianchetto again
yeah here maybe c5 as an alternative
maybe I don't know can you take it seems
it doesn't want to so let's get this pin
in and make more pressure on deform so
let's take interesting cam that's
probably not the best kind of benoni
other huh okay let's see maybe I can get
in East 6 like e6 takes rook cheeks yeah
I really feel I should try that if I'm
just sitting there with no kind of play
it won't be good so let's do that he can
take e 6 root chicks and f5 actually but
this might give me some play on the dark
squares now this might might be okay hmm
ok so that's rather greedy let's jump in
hmm so I've got quindi for check a night
after winning the exchange um question
is do I have more who have anything more
I have bishop f am also after that he
has to go queen bee three okay let's
let's take that shouldn't be bad in the
first place I wonder actually if I can't
play Knight takes e4 and rook takes the
form or if this is this is nonsense
probably it is nonsense ok so let's
let's get this I mean the thing is I'm
also threatening check made right away
with Queenie one so he has to has to
play the ship some web shop g5s probably
the the only sensible square white
resigns really why Bishop f4 stead lost
I don't see it I mean I understand that
is probably not very thrilled with what
he did because my opening play frankly
was pretty bad but it said lost I don't
don't quite get it this lost my it's got
two powerful bishops I don't know yeah
maybe he was just kind of frustrated
because this is really not good yeah and
this is really questionable if this is
this is any good yeah then I'm not even
sure okay that's interesting after 95
the comp gives me quite good good play
compensation surprisingly but after here
the the engine gives g4 and white is
much much better and yeah he just plays
g5 next I have no move for this night
and something like this and he's getting
together he gets an F sex that's a
disaster yeah yeah yeah ma'am okay I
admit it that wasn't no good that was no
good maybe I have to take here check
this is a bit more interesting maybe
it's a bit comparable to the gin Chi
Indian gingy line there with Bishop
takes you three yeah the problem is that
this is just modern not a very good bin
only because I don't get it 6n and if I
don't get you 6 and unjust worse I
cannot play b5 and i have no porn break
why just has a big center it's not that
the the Benoni is a god-given great
formation you have to get some concrete
play otherwise it's just rubbish and
this is the rubbish version of it I
really don't have any play some are
related to this giving up the bishop
down on f3 yeah but okay the game is not
over you still have to play moves I mean
I've experienced it so often on the
other side here and here that's actually
not clear and now this is quite nice now
in fact the engine if just that as
better move oh yeah I see from four yeah
yeah of course I'm threatening here
I was just glad that I get this in I
actually saw this slide which is quite
nice for this but ok check a 94 was
stronger had this suspicion but I wanted
to cash in a little bit that looks that
looks strong an idea was this ah but the
computer gives I wasn't sure here right
because he can play I know something and
I'm not sure that i have a good move now
ok I've Luke edge form um the engine
gives that that's stronger that's nice
that's nice if the night now moves
chatting meeting yeah I have the check
classic smothered mate check check check
mate always always cute and yeah yeah
there's also check checkmate also this
made so GTX is quite nice Chad was even
better than grabbing the exchange but
he'd resign far too early probably just
being frustrated on whatever maybe you
also just had to leave you never know ok
well thanks for watching